พี่ปิน
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
100 คนโหเรามีนักเรียนผู้ชายผู้หญิง
100 คนเลยเหรอคะ
ว้าว
เยอะไหมเยอะดีมากค่ะคุณป๋าแต่ว่านักเรียน
เนี่ยอยากฟังแล้วว่าวันนี้วันอะไรคะครู
ฟ้า
วันนี้วันศุกร์ค่ะนิดศุกร์
วันศุกร์ที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันศุกร์ที่ 14 ค่ะวันศุกร์ที่ 24 เดือน
อะไรคะครูฟ้า
เดือนมกราคม
มีตลาดผมปีพตต
ปีพตต
25652 บ้าอก 5 นะคะปีคศอะไรคะ
ปีคศ 2  022
2022 แล้วเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไร
เมื่อวานนี้วันพฤหัสบดี
วันพฤหัสบดีที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันพฤหัสบดีที่
15  10  13 เมื่อวานเขาหวาน
13 เดือน
เดือนมกราคม
ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะแล้วพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรเหรียญพระ
ครูฟ้า
พรุ่งนี้วันเสาร์
วันเสาร์ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันเสาร์ที่ 15 ค่ะ
15 เดือน
เดือนมกราคม
ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะวันนี้ก็วันศุกร์แล้วเย้เย้
[เพลง]
แล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงแล้วคะครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
11:00 น
11:00 น 11 โมงนะเจ็ดโมงกี่นาทีคะ
28 นาทีค่ะอ่ะแต่ตอนนี้เวลา 11:00  28
นาทีไม่มีเฟซก็เป็นเวลากลางวันกลางวัน
แล้ว
ที่อเมริกากี่โมงแล้วคะที่อเมริกาเนี่ยนะ
คะก็จะเป็นเวลา
ติ๊กต๊อกติ๊กต๊อกป้าทุ่มยี่สิบแปดนาที
เป็นเวลากลางคืนค่ะกลางคืนถ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ย
ครูฟ้ากลางวันนครูหญิงก็กลางคืนเวลาไม่
เหมือนกัน
ใช่ไหมโอวห่างกัน 12 ชั่วโมงใจฟังซึ่งวัน
นี้เนี่ยคะก็เพราะเวลามันห่างกัน 12
ชั่วโมงใช่ไหม
12 ชั่วโมงเนี่ย
เหมาเน้อ
ขอฟังครูฟ้าก็ไม่รู้เวลาครูหญิงครูหญิงก็
ไม่รู้เวลาครูฟ้าว่าครูหญิงกับครูฟ้า
เนี่ยตัวเลขเนี่ย 12 เนี่ยป่ะ
ไม่ชอบและไม่ชอบชอบ
สายครูฟ้าเนี่ยไม่ชอบชอบไหมคะ
บวก
ลบๆบวกกับลบนะครูฟ้าชอบไหมคะ
ไม่ห่าไม่ชอบไม่ชอบบวกไม่ชอบลบไปซอยชอบ *
*
ไม่ชอบถ้าไม่เป็นไรเพราะว่า
คูณเนี่ยไม่มีหรอกไม่มี
มันนี้เนี่ยครูหญิงครูหญิงนะคะจะให้ครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยเล่นเล่นเกมส์
บวกอิ่มเราก็ลบ
[เพลง]
เกมบวกลบนิยายค่ะครูฟ้าต้องคิดคิดๆต้อง
คิดนะเดี๋ยวขอคุยอิง Share  screen แป๊บ
นึงนะคะได้เลยฮะเล่นยังไงนะ
ยังไม่มาใช่ไหมคะให้หายยังลด
[เพลง]
สิ่งที่กำลังมามาแล้วอ่ะอ่านี่ค่ะเกมบวก
ลบ
มีอะไรบ้างเนี่ย
ว่าใช่ไหมคะอันแรกเนี่ยเราอันแรกนะคะมี
เชอรี่ 1  2  3  4  5  6
คะเชอร์รี่ 6 ลูก
บวกเชอรี่ 4 รูป
เท่ากับเท่าไหร่คะกูมาเขียนหรอมาเขียนเลย
ค่ะ 6  +  4  market ได้เลยค่ะตัวเลข
6  +  4  =
สิพ่อมีเชอรี่ 10 ลูกเนาะอันเชอรี่ข้อที่
สองนะคะครูฟ้าอันนี้อะไรเนี่ยสาลี่เนาะ 1
2  3  4  5  6  7
สาลี่ 7 รูปเนาะบัวกนี่เป็นบวกสาลี่ 3
ลูก
ทั้งหมดมีสาลี่เท่าไหร่คะ
ทั้งหมดนะมีทั้งหมดมีสาลี่ติดลูกอ๋ออะข้อ
ที่ 3 ใช่ไหมคะ Apple  4 รูปบวก
แอปเปิ้ล 2 ลูกเท่ากับ
แอปเปิ้ลกี่ลูกคะ
Apple สีรูปบวกแอปเปิ้ล 2 ลูกเท่ากับ
แอปเปิ้ล 6 ลูกค่ะหินเห็นมากนะคะคือฟ้า
ข้อที่ 4 ค่ะ Apple สีเขียวเนาะ 5 ลูก +
แอปเปิลสีเขียว 3 รูปเท่ากับแอปเปิ้ลกี่
ลูกคะ
Apple สีเขียว 5 รูป + แอปเปิลสีเขียว 3
ลูกเท่ากับ Apple  8 ลูกเขาก็คือ 5  +  3
เท่ากับ 8 เนาะ
เก่งมากค่ะครูฟ้าตอกอะไรนี่ก็บวกแล้วก็มา
ลบบ้างหรออ่ะแอปเปิ้ลสีเขียว 1  2  3  4
5  6  7  7 รูปลบ apple สีเขียว 3 ลูก
หรือเหลืองแอปเปิ้ลกี่ลูกคะ
Apple สีเขียว 7 ลูกลบ apple สีเขียว 3
ลูกเท่ากับ Apple สีเขียว 4 ค่ะต่อ 4 ลูก
เนาะ
Lemon  3 ลูกลบเรม่อน 2 ลูกเหลือ Lemon
กี่ลูกคะ
Lemon  3 ลูกหรือลบเรม่อน 2 รูปเหลือ
Lemon  1 ลูกค่ะ
แอปเปิ้ลสีแดง 1  2  3  4  5  6  7  8  8
รูปลบแอปเปิ้ลสีแดง 1
1344 ลูกเหลือแอปเปิ้ลกี่ลูกคะ
แอปเปิ้ลสีแดง
8 รูปลบแอปเปิ้ลสีแดง 4 ลูกหรือแอปเปิ้ล
สีแดง 4 ลูกค่ะ
ส้ม 1  2  3  4  4 รูปลบส้ม 3 ลูกเหลือ
ส้มกี่ลูกคะ
ส้มสีลูก - ส้ม 3 ลูกเหลือส้ม 1 ลูกค่ะ
ขอขอบคุณค่ะ
รถไม่เอาแล้วมันง่ายไปอันนี้เป็นหรือยัง
เกลียดปลาหมึกสวยเป็นปลาหมึกแล้วก็ต้องวง
กลมในก็จะมี
96  2  1  4 นะฮะอะครูฟ้า
6-5 เท่ามีเท่าไหร่กูฟ้าวเขียนลมวงกลม
ตรงตัวเลขบนปลาหมึก
อ้าหนึ่งใช่มั้ยฮะพูดเก่งเนาะ
อร่อยจังคะนี้เนี่ยอ่ะที่ 2 นะ 3  +  3
เท่ากับเท่าไหร่คะ
6 ขอบคุณมากเลยค่ะ
อะไรนะคะ
ลบ 4 เท่ากับเท่าไหร่คะ
4  5
[เพลง]
ต่อไปนะคะ 5  +  5  = เท่าไหร่คะ
15 บาท
[ปรบมือ]
ต่อ
4  -  2 เท่ากับเท่าไหร่คะอ่ะ
ตีสองหน้า
แย่ก็สุดท้าย 1  +  8  = เท่าไหร่คะ
9 ค่ะ
เก่งมากครูฟ้าอ่ะต่อไป
ต่อไปนะคะอันนี้ก็จะเป็นเกมหรออันนี้เป็น
กล่องนะคะกล่องเนี่ยเท่ากับ 5 เท่ากับ 5
หมวกเท่ากับ 3
อันนี้อะไรคะช็อกโกแลตร้อนเท่ากับสองแล้ว
ก็ลีแล้วจะเป็น
Candy ลูกอมเท่ากับ 7  =  7 นะอ่ะครูฟ้า
ข้อที่ 1 เนี่ยอันแรกนะกล่องบวกหล่องบวก
ล่องเท่ากับเท่าไหร่
กล่อง + กล่อง + กล่องเท่ากับ 15 ค่ะค่ะ 1
กล่องเท่ากับเท่าไหร่คะจะเป็นห้าใช่มั้ย
ฮะถ้าอ่า
ใช่มั้ยเป็นท่า
+  5
+ ค่า
ข้อที่สองหมวกบวกหมวกลบช็อกโกแลตร้อนเท่า
กับเท่าไหร่คะ
หมวก =  3  +  3 นะคะลบช็อกโกแลตร้อนก็
คือสองเท่ากับ 4
ง้อจะต่อไปนะคะ Candy
ลบช็อกโกแลตร้อน - หมวกเท่ากับเท่าไหร่คะ
Candy เท่ากับ 7 ช็อกโกแลตร้อนเท่ากับ 2
นะคะหมวกเท่ากับ 3  =  2  5  7  -  2  -
3  =  2  7  - ตั้งค่าค่ารถ 3 เท่ากับ 2
ชัยอ่ะเก่งมากค่ะเข้าไปนะคะ Candy บวก
กล่องลบหมวกเท่ากับเท่าไหร่นะคะ
Candy เท่ากับ 7 นะคะบวกกล่องเท่ากับ 5
- หมวกเท่ากับสามเท่ากับ 9 มั้ย
7  +
52 ใช่มั้ยโอเค 12-9 ลบสามเท่ากับ 9 ใช่
ค่ะ
ยังเก่งอยู่ยังเก่งอยู่อ่ะต่อไปครูฟ้า
โอเคนะคะโอเคค่ะข้อแรกหรอ 2  +  3 เท่า
กับเท่าไหร่คะ
2  +  3  =  5 ค่ะฟ้า
8  -  5  = เท่าไหร่ที่
8  -  5  = ป่าวค่ะที่เรากับ
จบแล้วไปนะคะ 5  + อะไรเท่ากับ 9  5  +  4
อ่านต่อไป 7  - ไรเท่ากับ 4
7  -  3 ค่ะโต
เก่งมากนะกูฟ้าอ่านต่อไปนะคะอะไร +  6  =
2 โต๊ะอะไร -  1  =  4
5  K
[เพลง]
ถ้าเราได้ siku ฟ้าลบไปผู้หญิงว่ามันบอก
โอเคอ่อนมันออกมั้ยไม่ออกไม่เป็นไรอะอะ
อันนี้ในรูปน้องมีคนสมัยมีเด็กเด็กผู้
หญิงมาเด็กผู้หญิงเด็กผู้ชายแล้วก็หมานะ
คะอ่ะครูฟ้าคะในรูปมีเด็กผู้หญิงกี่คน
ในรูปนะคะมีเด็กผู้หญิง 1
2  3  4  4  5  5  6 ห้าหกนักศึกษาก็ใส่
ในครบ
6  5 แล้วเด็กผู้ชายกี่คน
เด็กผู้ชาย
2  3  4  5
เด็กผู้ชาย 5 คนออกปะแล้วมีหมากี่ตัว
มีหมา 1  2  3
4  4  5  5  6
อันเนี้ย 7 ตู้
แล้วน่ะไม่ใช่หมาไหม
7 ตัว
เสียมีมา 7 ตัวเพราะฉะนั้นเด็กผู้หญิง 6
คนใช่ไหมคะเด็กผู้ชาย 5 คนหมา 7 ตัวเนาะ 6
+  5  +  7 เท่ากับเท่าไหร่ทั้งหมดมีใน
รูปมีทั้งหมดกี่คนกี่ตัว
ทั้งหมดเท่ากับ 18 คนและตัวอ๋อ
60  +  5 เท่ากับ 11 ใช่ไหม 11  + ที่
เย้อ่าอ่ะต่อไป
วันนี้ง่ายกว่านั้นเนาะอ่า
อันแรกเนาะ
มีอันแรกกีฬาหน้าละกี่ตัวคะคือฟ้ากูว่า
เขียนข้างล่างเลยหรอเห็นไหมบ้างล่าว
3 ตัวค่ะมีดีอะไรเนี่ย Monster กี่ตัว
สองตัวแล้วก็มีอะไรเนี่ยคอนเซอร์อีกกี่
ทัวร์อ้าๆ 4 ตัวแล้วก็มีผู้ชายกี่คน
ห้าคนหนึ่งสองสามสี่ห้าคนเนาะ 3  +  2  +
4  +  5  = เท่าไหร่คะทั้งหมดเท่ากับ 14
ค่ะหนังโป๊ 14 คนเนาะเก่งมากฟ้า
OK
อะไรนะมัน
อ๋อ
ไงก็ต้องมียากครูฟ้าทำให้ผู้ฟ้าถ้า
อันนี้ไงใช่ไหวมากภาษาอังกฤษออกไปนะคะนัก
เรียนเข้าใจ
ช่าโอเคกูฟ้าสี่เหลี่ยมแรกน้อ 10  +  10
เท่ากับเท่าไหร่คะ
20 หักแล้วก็ฟ้าดูลงมาเนาะลงมานะคะ 10  +
6  = เท่าไหร่คะติด 6 ค่ะไม่ค่อยเขียน
เดี๋ยวหน้า
16 อะแล้วก็ช่องต่อไปนะคะ 10  +  4 เท่า
กับเท่าไหร่
500 ที่ดูแนวนอนแนวนอน 6  +  4 เท่ากับ
เท่าไหร่คะติดหาแล้ว 16 ปวก 4 เท่ากับ
เท่าไหร่คะ 16  +  14 เท่ากับ 36  14
แล้ว 20  +  10 หรอคะเท่ากับสามสิบ
มีฟ้าเก่งมากนะๆมาทำช่องต่อไปได้ไหมได้
ค่ะเจ้าบวก 4 เท่ากับ 10  3  9  +  1  =
10  13  +  10  =
23 นะคะตี +  1  =  5  5 ชัดอันนี้อะไร
ออก
ไม่ใช่สร้าง 23 ทำอะไร
อะไรบวกหน้าร้อนเท่ากับ 23
9  +  9  =  18 ต่อกันเป็น 18 จะไป 18  +
ผ้าก็เท่ากับ 23
[เพลง]
พอแล้วเนาะได้ค่ะเอาคู่ฟ้าที่หัวเป็น
เป็นเกมหรอเกี่ยวกับตัวเลขนะคะแต่ว่ามี
แค่อ่า
มีแคบบวกเนาะบวกกับลบราคาให้นักเรียนลอง
เล่นแล้วก็ฟังภาษาไทยนะคะนักเรียนทำได้
ไหมเนาะตอบถูกนะถูกเหมือนครูฟ้าหรือเปล่า
นะคอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้นะคะจะไม่ทำวีดีโอ
นี้เราสองคนก็ต้องไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเจอกัน
ใหม่วิดีโอหน้าเนาะบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ
ม.ค